all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 60
it's another glorious Sunday we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got the future of Halo Xbox
financials Detroit became human demo
quantum dream versus the French media
and the future of the Nintendo switch to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
Nintendo when my opinion is one of the
top journalists in the game whether it
be his informative news articles
passionate opinion pieces and detail
product reviews this Lord always
exemplifies professionalism yet his core
remains a true gamer at heart although
this Lord is fearless and outspoken with
his opinions he's always willing to
engage in a respectful debate while
still being one of the most humble and
approachable personality in these gaming
streets introducing the Xbox / Microsoft
editor for Windows central.com and the
co-host of the Xbox 2 podcasts the Lord
of sarcastic humor fellow cat lover
capable of rocking a tiara with the
utmost royal swag way to debut into the
realm of the Lord's mom head Lord just
Gordon how you doing sir I'm good man
some intro to the red carpet was gonna
be rolled out Goodman one
I got caffeine in me some games playing
games all weekend to do too much work
I've been I've been editing a lot of
slave decay to footage
like that really like that huge fan of
undead we got a chance to all the Lord
most laws got a chance to touch it at
PAX East and out man we were impressed
we can't wait to see what you got
cooking up with that yeah he would you'd
found what you do is so it's only right
that we shoot the proper respect at the
round table so let's get into the Four
Horsemen of gaming my co-host with the
Col most my brother from another mother
the difficult game Conqueror and the
howl of the young wolf my man Lord
addict are you doing sir I'm doing
pretty good I guess we're gonna talk
about this switch stuff but it's glad to
be here it's glad to have someone as a
as royal as a lord jazz here with this
alright let's get this going absolutely
fun and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Thomas
mr. offline profile Illuminati himself
my Ben Lord sovereign how you doing sir
fantastic great you know recovering from
infinity war had to like soak all that
in you know a lot of people are in the
recovery mode oh so that's it and of
course the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the XS gamer the lord of combat sports
was a man of his convictions demands
nothing less than the premium experience
and is to get money game at beloved Lord
King how you doing sir we are doing
incredible like the whole you see this
is don't break these guys this is
exactly what stole Riggle it's like oh
you know what I've never has it I've
always wondered what I'd like to hit you
with and now you guys
as long as you see it and i weld it i'ma
bust your forehead with some combat
sports last night and I'm getting
flat-out
fall asleep taking nodoz pills I gotta
say that oil salesman and it's horrible
what he does the boxing helmet HBO is
destroying what boxing it should be when
combat sports is all about he put
together a crappy show last night let's
say Danny Jacobs only almost lost to a
tomato can a bum one man um and it was
funny it was good I wish you would've
lost yesterday because you're putting
crap together I'm not gonna get into it
really be honest with you to tell you
the truth combat sports put me to sleep
last night kept me awake infinity war
make sure you go see this I don't care
what you doing take the baby's drawing a
week if you got kids you gotta watch him
take your kids with you it's good it's
good to the family is a fun family film
um my sneak and go see it alone but I'm
gonna tell you to make sure that you see
this if you're a marvel head or if you
just love action-packed good movies go
see it mom I gotta see it multiple times
I'm not gonna give any spoilers I'm
gonna give you one week to see it and
I'm going in very hard next week um but
no combat sports today jess is in the
building we're about to do this whole
shebang I got storm a storm breaker and
I got Lillian in the back but he's
broken because he'll at all breaker
right now because that's the thing
that's smoking right now Oh real quick
baby looking for a combat sports recap I
know there was just one MMA fight did
you see it no I you know what
it's a battle of the old men and I asked
and I did not see it no and I don't know
the result so we don't want to put no
just asleep because he knows I know yeah
it was big much a battle of the old man
and we had a The Last Emperor fate fedor
emelianenko and he was fighting one of
the veterans of UFC Frank Mir so it was
one round boombastic slugfest and
surprisingly the old man hey old Frank
Mir put him to sleep in the fetal
position yeah it was yeah it was bad I
mean for he rocked fatal I mean actually
Frank rocked fate off first and then um
fate I just they literally just going it
was a slugfest he just literally going
that he caught him with with a hook and
the next thing you know yeah his body
was crazy because Frank is bigger than
Fedor and at this point you know faders
if you have a watch all faders all
fights like it is scary to stand in
front of yes who comes at you like an
animal like he swings with reckless
abandon kill you yes yeah yeah and it
knew what it is he actually tagged him
early the problem is Frank's chin at
this stage in their career both of them
their chins are you know so it is what
it is there was the old goats out there
putting on a show for Bellator spreadin
everyone is in the realm of the IOP not
telling you what you want to hear but
what you need to hear so before we get
into what the Lords are playing this
week I want to start off with Lord jazz
his video game system history his
passion for the Microsoft brand and
journey the Windows central
of course what led him to the creation
of one of my favorite podcasts which any
one of my favorite content creators Lord
rained in the Xbox too so not just I
start from the very beginning on a
gaming level what were the first kind of
video game systems did you had the first
video game system I had was the Sega
Master System economic reason that some
reason Nintendo games were way more
expensive in the UK than Sega game I had
there was a second it was like a
secondhand store near where I lived they
always had Mega Drive games but they
never had Sega and Nintendo games ever
so I did have a Super Nintendo but I
only had like Super Mario all-stars
yeah Yoshi's Island Super Metroid and
star wink as it was called in the UK it
was called Star Fox in in America I
believe I don't know why it had a
different name in the UK but it did for
some reason copyright thing I like that
then 64 Star Fox was called lylat wars
in the lylat wars the same game just
that different there so but yeah mostly
played on the sega system so like
Streets of Rage heroes let's go on sonic
sonic the treasure games man like
dynamite Headdy altered beast
what alright you've written up the
fields now then let me let me back you
up one sec where's Sega Master System so
my question was and you said that the
Tendo games were more expensive in UK at
that point now did you ever had a
classic NES or you just skip that and
went Sega Master System into Genesis I
didn't even know the NES existed I was
like but you gotta bear in mind I was
like six years old you know I like the
Sega Master System and then I think my
my neighbor had Mega Drive or I copied
them and
Mega Drive Sega Genesis if the Mega
Drive had a different name in the UK
really say Sega Genesis mm-hmm America
but I was called the mega drive
everywhere else in Japan right and then
I did I was in hospital for six months
because I had I had a burst appendix but
it was on it went untreated so I had I
had sepsis have since Maha and when I
was in hospital I was bedridden but I
had a soup that I had a Super Nintendo
and the hospital provided and I just
fight Mario all day every day and then
when I got out of hospital my parents
got me a super Nintendos like again and
I got a Playstation one first for the
PlayStation 1 game well see now I don't
know if it was like this in America but
in the UK most PlayStation ones were
bundled with crash bandicoot which is
why like when Crash Bandicoot launched
again recently it was like shot straight
to the top of the UK charts because
every kid in that generation had crash
bandicoot because he was just bundled
with the PlayStation 1 so Crash
Bandicoot man I had so many games and
I've still got them I've still got my
parents like it's kind of crisis my
creatures odd world games Resident Evil
I was like was so so excited for isn't
evil to like I was hyped out of my mind
at like I bought every magazine had been
able to under covers I've never been
more hyped for a game before to be ok
dude that game it was so funny that you
mention it because I had the same level
excitement Resident Evil 2 it definitely
resonating with me and the thing about
it was remember you had to go through
like a second playthrough with the
second disc or something and I'll never
forget Lord King a little soft we
affectionately named that character that
appears unbeknownst to us that's we go
what was the de nemesis they come
through and started it didn't have I
don't think it I said I didn't wrong but
I'm not sure if he even had a gay a name
in the game yeah it was the most
unspoken feature it was like he was like
a code name or something like a tease 0
1 7 wasn't like tyrant everyone at
school used to call it the Hulk we call
the milodon we just made up a name he
was so I was so terrified when that
thing burst through the wall and it
would really chase you and harass you
like I had like set rules didn't they
like because that static backgrounds and
you expected the game to have these
rules and then you get used to monsters
not being able to go through the doors
like that and then the whole the whole
well I call it the whole he was able to
break through some of the walls and
stuff and then they took it even further
with nemesis I don't think any game
terrified me as much as the first time I
played resident evil nemesis it was like
I just I was like 11 years old and five
Resident Evil 3 and like the first time
you see him is outside the police
station memories no idea that's good we
had big-time Resident Evil heads who
refused to play three different than the
other game stars right you'd run all the
way back to the save room which is like
the only safe place but then even the
save room music which was usually like
sort of it was like ominous and he's
like you know when you leave the save
room he's gonna come back
outside absolutely that I'm so glad you
read that because for vegan residue
definitely resonated to have had that if
that's one of my favorite and I guess
because of the success of that character
they made a whole you know they agree
the game that the game that really made
me fall in love with the Hobby top
seeing it just like a toy I guess on a
fancy seven has now this is a weird
story I am my my parents used to buy me
games sometimes when like I did well at
school or whatever and um they bought me
men in black 2 for the PlayStation was
like where's the love I was like yeah so
I took it back to the shop and I was
like I want to exchange this game and
the guy the guy in the shop was like
well why don't you try this this is
quite popular apparently he just gave me
Final Fantasy 7 I never heard Final
Fantasy in my whole life like you know
there was no internet back then and I
didn't know many I didn't have many
gaming like that
so I never heard from fancy I was like
wow this is the seventh game you know
and I was like whoa it's on three discs
what is this is the huge first I was
like what are these little cartoon
characters and all this stuff and and
they're like as played is active and I
could night I named all the characters
after my school friend those I just got
sucked in again - oh great game and
that's that's big one for adequate fire
he says what is on your list dude yeah
seven Oh actually sevens really good I
feel like literally the entire to our
podcast I've been asleep for at least
but I mean go back on I have a song
where you want to be so get off of my
back did you learn any
one when it comes to when it comes to
Final Fantasy seven I feel like seven
help you know brought the whole
franchise on it but I don't know why but
if ten has more of a remnants on me than
seven does I think I I think my favorite
one just because the impact it had I'd
never played anything like that
my least favorite one is uh it said is a
I think I think it was because Louis I
mean seven as great as the others was
and I was kind of knew once I was new to
RPGs but I think seven I don't say
casual eyes objects but it opened up an
audience that never experienced it
before being in it was on PlayStation
and the fact let's keep it real
graphically at its time seven was
amazing I'll never forget what it was
released for me Lord jazz what really
did it for me is the summons remember
the summons like I think you had the
little materias where we had a little
material you put a boob and it was just
like wow just cinematic event you know
the real and I'm just like you I've
never seen I'd sit around remember nice
for the road that's most ridiculous some
endeavour things I've ever done in
gaming in general because it's not hard
it's just tedious it's like oh I beat
that game like at least ten times I've
only had nights the room once Wow I got
at one time and I was like that's good
enough for me I never need to get it to
you but say I'm bit I'm playing it on
the ps4 and there's actually a trophy
for so I'm sitting there dead I in the
trophy and I'm like dude is it really
worth there's other Disney to tell out
of people mr. materia system a yes ever
was iconic wait so you went from
PlayStation all that gray stuff don't
win did your Xbox and Microsoft c2000
start love start I was quite lucky
because I got lots of siblings I was the
oldest and like as I got older they got
older they got into gaming I like I
didn't have to buy a Nintendo consoles
cuz my brother got really into Nintendo
and ebooks
or the Pikachu at the red rosy cheek
it's the ladies console but also the
most awesome console over at the n64 and
then he bought em Cuban there's a nice
they make on that so I got to play that
as well like they weren't my console
brothers consoles whereas I sort of went
the other way and you know I station to
like that and then I did get I bought
the original Xbox with because the time
the UK government were paying kids to
stay in school
really yeah they like stuff that's
relevant to everyone like it was a you
could argue is a bit of a waste of money
because like that they were paying kids
from poorer backgrounds about forty
dollars a week the stay in school right
and so I was getting I was getting like
forty dollars a week just for turning up
to school used to go into school get my
checkmark and then climb under the fence
nobody I knew was spending that money on
on educational stuff they were spending
it on like we used to just go to a
supermarket and buy a remote-control car
and drive it around the playground and
then just leave it there you know
everyone is just wasting all these poor
kids had money and they didn't know what
to do this lion cake like finally
predict but they cakes and wedding cakes
and just diabetes at this period of time
I I saved my money and I bought the
original Xbox on a whim just because I
wanted because me and my brother had
this thing like we need to own every
console somehow amongst our King so I
bought the original Xbox but I didn't
have that many games for again I just
used to buy all the multiplayer on the
ps2 so like I only really had a halo on
the Xbox and like I bought all the multi
plats on ps2 but and I missed a lot of
those classic original Xbox games that
were Xbox
I missed a lot of them like like halo no
i hella was the only one I did have
talking like I felt like there was no
marketing for any of you of the game so
I just wasn't really aware of them so
but then when it came to the ps3 xbox
360 generation Sony just priced me out
the market oh how many pounds was it was
it like I can't remember but it was it
was just too much
I was like no I'll just get a 360 what
because it was significantly cheaper and
lights and at the time it was like the
ps3 came with blu-ray it came with Wi-Fi
built in and it was like I don't need
either of those there's iron there's
very few times on my marketing history
to where it's not even like a joke like
you see it there's just like it's kind
of like what happened I didn't even have
a Wi-Fi truer back then you know I just
plugged straight into the just--even it
so I just I just bought an Xbox 360 and
never looked back
yes yes and again I wasn't really into
360 and the time cuz I started getting
more into PC gaming awesome world of wok
I lost years of my life
I get off the game when I realized that
in one week I spend like 100 then the
following week I spent 150 to get gold
yes Oh God is right you understand talk
but we put meat up and she would because
she was she was able to make clothes
that was like and because I got into the
game he knows he knows my sovereign was
yeah what's the gold addiction started
setting as a note that's it I cut it off
back to my half-life to let me go back
to my so my doom 3 no I was not messing
with I was scared of it I heard stories
and I'm Lord Kings to tell me play it
how intense it was I was like
intimidated by that game I can't that
game looks do it dude it was bad I was
the guy from the South Park episode
listen I was literally that guy you know
I think go outside I didn't have a job
Warcraft all day every day I'm gonna be
the best damn paladin's planet so I lost
years of my life for that and I missed a
lot of early 360 years because of
since I go on my pc broke my pc broke
that let me back to the 360 and man this
is a long story but go for it well
honestly it wasn't really Xbox that made
me getting Microsoft logging it was
actually Windows Phone because well it
kind of was Xbox but like I heard that
on Windows Phone you can get Xbox
achievements for play mobile games so
that was that was literally the selling
point for me nice and also there was
this girl whose boyfriend I know this is
the first time I've ever encountered a
fanboy a tech fanboy he was he was an
Apple fanboy Apple logos look to his
front door and he didn't like me because
I was good friends with his girlfriend
to piss him off
I think I started saying how great
Microsoft was all the time and and I got
a go it was because of him that I got a
Windows Phone just to contradict his
iPhone but somehow I got like in my
crusade to piss him off
learned a lot about Microsoft in their
ecosystem and what they're planning to
do this I was off setting his Apple
fanboys and then I discovered like
Microsoft making its ecosystem where
they'll go Xbox on all these devices and
I was like well this is actually quite
interesting you went on a long-term con
to upset someone you ended up flipping
back ended up flipping around on you
you ended up you ended up actually
committee to which you were trying to
make him think I am the biggest question
is did you get the girl mmm
was it successful is the mission
successful no jet well I was you know in
anime like where they sighed the
childhood friend never win I met my
girlfriend
it was trolling you know you know we
know you're synonymous with a window
central and stuff like that so I start
with the journalistic journey like how
did that whole star I know what the
connection you had that love there
starting there but how did you actually
get into this I was working as an IT
technician at a school at the time and I
I self taught web design when I was at
school again to troll people learn to
learn web design because we wanted to
set out forums to talk about games and
we set up one real tournament forums and
stuff like that so I learn web design
because I wanted my PHP forum to look
nicer and so when I was working at its
high school their web sites really
sucked and I was just like I can make
those websites maybe so I updated my
skills using YouTube and then there was
this guy that guy who I was trolling and
it's time to get really
gently into disproving him and then the
whole Xbox one thing dropped now he he
was like he was like one of those guys
who were like in 2013 oh my god
Microsoft that evil erm yeah all that
all that stuff blew up and I thought I
was oh yeah I was sucked into it so much
that I was like I'm gonna and he was a
twitter user as well so I got on Twitter
contradict him again mmm um I I just
sort of saw that there was this sort of
community of like bloggers and youtubers
like much like yourselves and central of
my back I just covered with no central
and and I was like you know I want to do
this stuff as well and I've told myself
web design and I met this guy called
Liam pond
who's on Twitter Utley and Sharons him
he used to be called Xbox mad UK oh yes
I met him he was like pretty well cool
and Xbox community and he supported the
original 2013 vision my eye support as
well and we were like you know console
boring you know defending it you fight
the good fight fighting a losing battle
is often the case from there we made
made Xbox mad dotnet block site just say
just copy copy or the blog sites really
just writing about stuff well somehow I
discovered that I was pretty good at it
and we were the only website at the time
writing about Windows Phone for an echo
from an Xbox perspective no the not the
nokia PR team got in touch with me they
were like we want to we want to elevate
you you know so we want to invite you to
Barcelona
to see the next Windows Phone get
revealed in Oslo no and I was like oh my
god that's amazing so
I went to Barcelona nice on Microsoft
dime holla
I covered the launch of the Lumia 640
this you know terrible slow phone it was
amazing because I in my first interview
with Nokia VP of Marketing and stuff
like that and I posted the interview on
Xbox mad and I talked about like could
could we see Xbox evolved on phones like
I've got a vote on ready and then Daniel
Rubino who runs Windows central sent me
an email and offered me a job I was like
oh my god okay mm-hmm I owed an $80
whiskey on lots of credit card did you
feel like your baby I was like well I
was like this is never gonna happen
again so I'm gonna make the most of it
and I asked the barman you meet the most
expensive whiskey I was like it's real
so I wanted to next move our transition
forward with the into the podcast game
because obviously you are part of one of
my favorite podcast with Lord ran in the
Xbox - how did that get started
well I add my own podcast with Matt
Brown at Windows Central because
workloads quite crazy when essential
some days days I'd have to postpone we
wouldn't match with him postponing so
there'd be times when like we wouldn't
podcast
for like several week because neither of
us had the flexibility a Rand Rand does
have a flexibility so like if I need to
delay because work you able to do it on
Thursday or Friday which is really great
work so I'm and I just runs a great guy
like it remains awesome I think we have
a pretty good chemistry we don't always
agree on everything but you know that's
Mike's podcasting interesting I guess
absolutely you know honestly I can't
even remember how the podcast came about
remember we did our 51st episode is
there like I remember like kind of early
things is the interesting pairing and
then I kind of listen you guys anything
like you said like the chemistry you got
to have but what like you also what you
say which I like about it in which I
actually love about our podcast is that
we all don't agree we like an addict
definitely of polarizing at times
probably solvers the closest I resent
that you guys still get along but at the
same time having different viewpoints on
stuff and I'll actually love how
passionate you get with like but with
certain things in reference to the
fanboys and in the council so much time
was going [ __ ] we was at tax when
you blew up to me um just recent axle
just happened and walking through and we
was with another jazz and I'm texting
somebody and cuz they tweeted me they DM
me he got so so horrible he got off of
regular Twitter and started yelling me
so I'm like I'm with jazz right now he
said not that jazz you idiot
look and then I started going through
the timeline with the tweets and then
I'm like I'm on Jays side no way he what
he said was right I said so needless to
say you blowing up then you were pop I
mean you were trending some crazy I have
this tendency to tweet first and think
like it's dead ablaze the social space
of blaze we actually all question we're
getting suppose a little bit it's fine
though sometimes Twitter needs a little
fire yeah you know obviously the whole
situation we had a question about media
bias and things of that nature so we'll
get into that but we're gonna say real
quick before we move on with your
history on as far as I know you're a fan
of the long dark franchise like myself
love that game absolutely love that game
so um and it shout out to Raphael I
believe he's really cool one of the devs
on the game I'm meeting him when it was
initially not getting preview but I
wanted to get to your last five your top
five video games of all time it could be
you could just go the games itself or
the franchise whenever people ask me
these questions
I always respond with the first thing
that come to mind because if you
overthink it then it's yes it's kind of
wrong the first thing that came to mind
straight away is Final Fantasy 7 what
what I what I owe it in terms of getting
me in I guess and I've got to say World
of Warcraft
even though us it's world walkers reared
weird because most of my memories of the
game are just sort of anger yeah I
played it so much that no other game
I have like I added up all the plate on
of all my characters and I think it came
out to over a year play time I think
like no snow the no of the game in
history is gonna achieve what exactly so
you already see impact that's the impact
it had on you like I've still got like
my best friend in real life I've got
right now they met him in World of
Warcraft
wow that's was something he moved to he
was from is from Northern Ireland and he
moved to the UK for work and he ended up
moving to the moving to a city near to
me for work Wow red from being world
Walker friends to him real quick I mean
we've had this discussion before when we
did the the game struck four last last
ILP and you know Halo had that effect
for us and I know for me personally hate
it but that's knee had that effect for
me I mean one of my podcast mates that I
do a destiny podcast with advances I met
him at like a destiny con because we're
so crazy for this stupid game when it
first gets flawed is it you know shut
out the Frodo there's so many friends so
I'm glad that you mentioned world of
warcraft because it neck in that space
because it gets chose to show you the
impact of the game and how real
friendships can be formed because of it
three more three more let's go youhad
you know I can't help but say I think
Monster Hunter world is slowly slipping
into that top five now cuz I've been
I've got 160 I was played on that now
and it's like I don't think I've played
a game this gen as much as Monson's a
world now oh it's so great so deep they
keep adding new content to it they
recently added golf to Roth which is
like this giant golden dragon and it's
rich it's not it's not just like they
added a monster and just dumped it into
the world and it a whole new system for
this boss fight where you fight it
through like this huge cave like a siege
you know cannons and all this stuff and
mechanics are different and almost
reminds me of like when they first
started Ragnar hasta World of Warcraft
yes I said the base game the base ending
and then they built on that endgame and
if most of the world keeps doing this I
think it's gonna be absolutely
absolutely absolutely the content had
been adding there's been tremendous you
got two more let's go come on I want to
say I really want to say Bioshock the
original BioShock nice I think I think
that was just something true absolutely
part twist wasn't crazy and like
whenever people ask me every games
that's one of the games that absolutely
one more one more I'm gonna have to say
again off the top of my head off the top
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's just such a it was just a
tremendous game influence on me I still
I still to stage dream when I dream
about zombies and listening evil to
zombies what about the dog did the dogs
build out [ __ ] of bed nice to read this
history love hearing about that as far
as games and far as a journey so that's
real cool so we gonna get into this poll
on these topics get this thing problem
so um yeah last week all results are in
and the people have spoken to the
question when neutral gaming media
outlets run imagery our articles that
may be perceived a folk poke fun of one
platform over another do you consider
this to be media bias against that
platform the winner at 42 percent in a
4-way ILP Crowell pretty much cruising
to victory was the yes there are some
journalists who have bias group covered
it at second at 27% was the shallow
group you mad because your platform is
taking else the shallows were in the
building they were second place huh
coming in at third place at 18% was the
definitely media bias across the board
and coming in at last place at 13% was
that no media biased exists group
performance of the platform is key so
it's pretty much over 200 voters Lord
jazz I heard you hold you personally
responsible for this I did you take of
the storm created by this is another
situation where a tweet before I thought
I really thought about it first why I
didn't want to put Ryan McCaffrey in
that position because here's a genuinely
great guy and he's he didn't deserve all
the she go for that so I felt really bad
like when I tweeted that I was like I
wasn't thinking oh my god screw those
journalists I was thinking oh my god
that social media team are stupid hmm
and I tweeted that the social media team
was stupid one from IGN was tweeting me
saying you can't call them stupid and I
stand by that I think what they tweeted
was stupid no I
I'm not against jokes I've made plenty
of shots at peers for myself but the
difference is I don't have a platform of
50 million people and um and also like I
think when a platform of that size takes
that kind of shot mm-hm
it kind of gives ammunition to the most
toxic elements of gaming so that that's
why it annoyed me I think if it was the
other way around if it was my station
like if they put a Nintendo in that
picture as well it would ever know it
would have annoyed me just watch you
know it's kind of like you know and it
just felt like really poor timing it was
like yeah Microsoft's taking all this
flak you know the people people at
Microsoft are real people they've got
real feelings they see all these tweets
and stuff like that and I I do I am
close to it because
got no friends at Microsoft you know and
absolutely I know lots of people at
Microsoft and I feel close to it and I
felt like if I if I was pouring my life
and soul into trying to make Xbox a good
platform and then the biggest platform
gaming on the planet was openly mocking
what I was trying to achieve I would
feel really bad so I felt bad on behalf
of of them them let me ask you a quick
question though because I just want to
be fair to the other side and my
question to you is what about the people
who say look the only reason why markets
offer is getting killed is because
they're not putting out a great product
and that people always reference the
last generation and they'll say hey you
know did 360 was the dominant force and
ps3 was getting killed back then what do
you say to those people who who really
they feel that there's no bias at all
when those type of comments come out now
I don't believe I don't believe thing is
everyone's got their biases I mean to
eliminate bias you would have to be a
robot I'm not saying platform thing like
if you're an individual you're gonna
have bias right but the problem is when
when you do something that makes it seem
like the platform is reflecting that
bias that's the problem because that's
not just your platform
sometimes bias can be a good thing I
think because it can like say for
example if you are biased against Xbox
it might lead you to coming getting
feedback that a fan boy whose bias in
favor of Xbox wouldn't necessarily
arrive as Microsoft Microsoft wants
feedback wherever it can get it as long
as it's respectful and I was just I was
just saying like if a PlayStation fan
says Microsoft I don't like what you're
doing this is why I'm not buying your
system now bias in favor of Playstation
but still that's useful information
where Microsoft can inform their
decisions going forward about maybe
trying to bring them on board
no but when you're a journalist you're
gonna have biases as well I only write
about xbox so you could say I'm biased
in favor direction the the watchit
what's important as a journalist is to
try and see it from a level try and say
from different perspectives
try say with a level head of view it's
no good if you just sit in there saying
to microsoft you're the best you're the
best everything you do is amazing all
the time because hey no one will believe
your [ __ ] wrestling exactly you just say
nice things all the time and also it's
not useful it's honestly not useful to
Microsoft if you're just giving them
wins when they're losing then it's not
helping them to grow and get better so I
approach it / - I mean I don't know what
all journalists do it but I approach I
try and approach it from the position of
constructive criticism is the best way
forward though if that's me using my
bias in a constructive way that's the
way I try and do it and my boss Daniel
Rubino he says he's ethos is that we're
brand champions are witness or we try
and inform the good stuff but also
highlight the bad stuff and try and give
a voice to criticism in the platform to
valid criticisms of Expo at Microsoft
and Xbox and that's why that's what I
try and do and I think that's what Ryan
McCaffrey tries to do in the IGN
editorial team shows do yeah that's what
I think I guess you would that tweet
look at something like you know when
Ryan mark I forgot a lot of flack for on
his personal Twitter you know just
posting that you know Xbox fans just
want something on God workout we got a
lot of he and say even nothing wrong he
was just like you know we would like on
this side just to get that kind of a
caliber of a game that was nothing wrong
with that but he apologized for that the
problem with that particular tweet with
the images is that wasn't on you know
whoever is the equivalent and let's say
the person who tweeted it that wasn't on
his personal Twitter that was on IGN's
Twitter
right but like because it was it was it
was the social media team not like the
editorial team right but it was the
platform it's still the platform of
Twitter it has all their followers is
that's like me going on io piece Twitter
and posting something no one knows that
it's me no one knows that it's Cognito
they see that as iron Lords podcast they
don't see that as an individual person
good point good point
no founder stuff mana and I said it was
really intense shout out to everybody in
the poll who contributed anyway very
intent argument where we definitely
respect it you know saying and like I
said I thought what you did it generated
a good conversation so I wanted to
include that so what we're gonna get
into these topics they're allowed to get
into so I'm gonna talk about halo
wouldn't talk about the the future and
the importance of the franchise
obviously halo is very near and dear to
the Lord's we talked about it the game
struck for most of us had it in our game
strap for last week and I'm sure want to
talk about Phil Spencer's tweet and the
arm you know the exact role of halo as
far as the future we're hearing the
rumors of it going to PC also that whole
L I can't pronounce it elder I know mod
that cause a little bit of a controversy
so uh the star-lord Jays again you know
as far as the future of halo where do
you see it going
also the controversy in reference to
halo apparently going to PC what is your
feelings on this logic mmm no and now
people are really passionate about this
topic because people see halo as being
part of the export brand the identity
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
sentiment hello what if what it means to
be an Xbox gamer is often a wrapped up
in Halo all disclaimer I'm not a big fan
of blood in the games I grew up on him
real tournament and doom there's not
enough gore in Halo why can't I why
can't I rip the Prometheans arms off
super soldier why can't I you know
thinking about that bringing that up
Joe's do you think if they made a
straight-up crazy halo like the next
tailor was if they weren't playing
around it's like look this is not for a
little kid
and it just showed like I had like
executions and rip it off like the weeds
hands and stuff do you think that would
improve the overall brand it make my
people interested I don't know to be
honest I mean my the common sense is
that 18 right Mature rating is bad
because it means less people buy you
again because little kids can't buy a
game so that's often the case but I
think the I mean just thrown off topic
slightly but the the flood the flood
served that purpose right because you
could smash the flood a bit and it felt
more impactful than flying Prometheans
just sort of explode in this I am I was
seriously I just but um but you know
this this whole thing about high-low and
PC I think people just need to accept
that it's gonna happen right now shut
out the chat room could have to
interrupt I wanna shout to chat
we got a cow from the tech leader and
less Sun network we ever the original
energy people are saying that hey halos
been on PC already with one and two so
this shouldn't be anything new so it
continued largesse and reference to your
feelings on that the whole PC bit
specifically of it probably coming yeah
exactly I mean first of all hello has
been on PC or this is the focal minority
and he honestly is a minority when when
you look at the the wider Xbox Live
that's there 59 million Xbox Live uses
however however where you want to take
that there are milk there are tens of
millions of Xbox Live you I'd say any
man maybe like 10 percent or less of
those are on Twitter maybe less than
five percent less less than five percent
know about this l jury or mod most Xbox
gamers are out there playing games I
don't care about any stuff that's just
the fact and like their friends everyone
those are the facts sorry so when
Microsoft is looking at this issue
they've seen a passionate community of
modest bring halo back to PC they've
seen a passionate amount of people play
that mod and love it streaming that mod
that's free money yes would be ignoring
it's a dumb business decision to not
bring it to PC there is no no downside
to bring like the only downside is a few
fanboys emotion so what you say Lord J's
is that up like because the the
counter-argument to to this is that
people say hey you know you're devaluing
the console there's no reason for me to
buy an xbox now I'll just get a PC you
know what do you say to that contingent
Microsoft would say we don't care it's
part of the ecosystem Xbox is x86 it is
virtually a PC it runs on Windows it's
you know it's x86 architecture the
Master Chief collection is being rebuilt
for you to pay other 5s already that
code presumably would run across onto PC
fairly quickly with a few weeks we've
already got had a 5-4 jump PC right
which shows you can run there's no such
thing as a distinction between Xbox and
PC Windows 10 is just the one ecosystem
like Oh kidding I'm sorry
Microsoft doesn't make any money selling
consoles I make money selling game make
any money selling consoles they would
love if you know they could get people
subscribing to Xbox Live on PC but
that's never gonna happen because that's
just pcs always been an open point so
Microsoft will be more than happy for
people to get a PC my high low and PC is
where Microsoft wants to be and that's
where they're gonna be no I double ups
pick you in your opinion because I kind
of think that it's a lot of this is
prepped for actually the Master Chief
collection to come on PC probably first
right based on like I said the uwp
aspect and based on the fact that you
know full disclosure I'm in them you
know the program before them to get that
thing going so that's my guess do you
think that this announcement kind of
sets that up for a massive collection to
kind of come out again and be ready
they are heavily hinting at it aren't
they ill ill quoted that specific line
which said we look forward to the future
of classical NP yes at its base that is
basically them saying calm down we're
not ready to announce it just yet but
yes probably Master Chief
that's cheap play and it's gonna mean so
much free cash for Xbox and like if
you're an Xbox fan you should be
celebrating that because it means the
business is healthier means Microsoft
can reinvest that money into the console
bring you those games
I got award that everyone's really upset
about and Master Chief collection on PC
is a huge wad of free cash so I don't
know why anyone would be against that
okay let's get no I hate I hate when
you're coming from III definitely go for
I just wanna get a lord King and lost
our feeling on this whole you know
controversy the seats at Whittington
upset you know what this still made to
tweak so Lord King let's get you up for
what do you feel about the whole halo to
pc thing if you're holding off and I'm
not gonna buy an xbox one because it's
[Music]
go buy PC go spend that two thousand
dollars to play Halo and I'll play Halo
with the 49 50 and what is it five
hundred dollars for the X system I'll do
that you let me know how your experience
is greater than mine or how it devalued
me and your value is so crazy I don't
care to be honest with you I don't care
like he said Microsoft is getting paid
just for selling games sell all the
games you can solve all the games
through all the avenues that you have
they Avenue is Windows our store on the
PC I would want them to buy steam so
they can take over steam rolling just
like upset the PC families oh I don't
care about the PC family
boys are really you know if this is
gonna be a controversial statement go
for a lot of them are pirates all right
a lot of them want free stuff anyway
cuz you feel entitled because you paid
two thousand dollars so you think you
should get everything for free so you
pirate in and mod and doing all this
stuff so no I don't really care about
your opinion because half of the stuff
you got is free anyway I hope they shut
you down the chat is in agreement with
you mother thank you for riding with the
king and spawn breaker says hey little
PC and the future available Microsoft
doesn't care where you get their game so
long as you get a game like they don't
care they happy to sell it to you an
Xbox the foot is like law just says like
it's free money to bring it to the PC
you got to remember I bought halo 1 & 2
on PC as well the community around that
was nothing compared to what you saw on
consoles your support for those games at
that time that's 2003 I would such a
huge hit back then we would halo with
everything right so I wanted to consume
halo ever came out and the game was
prettier it Ram it didn't run this good
though like I had a fairly powerful PC
and it was there was just a lot of jank
eNOS with so he the overall experience
was just better on consoles let me ask
you this question because I want to shut
up Mike I'm in a chat he's he's against
it because he's saying he thinks
cross-play sucks
he thinks his PC hackers who run sheets
so do you think it's off you think
Marcus or should I control that either
have like a toggle n talk long kind of
like what they had with Gears or what do
you feel about that aspect of cross play
that maybe some of the console guys are
worried that you know the PC guys would
have a distinct advantage I mean that's
always a possibility
obviously right you'd have to look into
like you know keyboard and mouse support
across the board stuff like that right
and and separate servers maybe
you know PC and console gave me that's
the sort of stuff but again this this is
stuff that's gonna be important down the
line for a lot of games I can you talk
about fortnight and all that stuff and
pop G with all this platform across
bathroom stuff this is stuff that on a
on a base level all of these companies
are looking into and how to how to
maintain and how to manage so this is
not it's gonna be an issue but it's an
issue that they've definitely addressing
right so this is not something that
they're blind to it's gonna be addressed
but the fact of the matter is that
monies who proceeds everything it is a
good business decision for the life of
Halo 4 the foot for that you gotta
remember to like okay part of the reason
halo is kind of has been on a downward
trend and I'm hoping six changes that is
that the multiplayer especially for five
which is amazing has been isolated to
the Xbox and you haven't you don't have
that sort of community support if you
had that game on PC as well right with
that same type of support same thing
from Master Chief collection be let's
let's forget about halo five right
Master Chief collection was the one that
was supposed to put everybody in it
feels like oh my god they're giving me
all my old games the entire halo legacy
with the multiplayer that I loved and
the PC players don't get to engage in
that at all it just doesn't make sense
and I understand on a fundamental level
that the multiplayer stuff had been kind
of broken and they're they're working on
that they're fixing that now's the
perfect time to give it to everybody
like these PC players never played halo
3 on PC never played halo 4 no ODST no
reach no nothing like oh there's another
angle to this from this this is a
perfect way to start game PC gamers
subscribing to game passing gonna pay
for Xbox Live so how do you get them to
pay for service you give the exactly
these Dinklage's you exactly I mean
that's exactly it
what do you do if you want to get P that
the whole business model over the Xbox
platform is on ramping to subscription
service
they say the console it's razor thin
margins and then they upsell you our
services and software software and
services have much better margins you
know and that's how they make money and
that's why Xbox has been a margins in
Playstation because Xbox is better
monetizing its platform and it has you
know operating costs because they got my
mind
racin when you when you make that Master
Chief game pass comment do you think
Master Chief collection will launch in
to the game pass service what it does
come out but if I was Microsoft yes I
would release halo 1 1 hello - hello 3
the next role at heart isn't as evil as
me throw it all out there in the wild
make them have to click that button say
yeah I mean game because interesting
but I think it'll be interesting like if
they if they bring NASA chief collection
out piece-by-piece like just giving them
ammunition you want the page to light up
I was talking to I was talking someone
at Xbox earlier about fishing in sea of
thieves now I was saying to them you
know what you could add fishing as a
game Plus subscriber only feature
instead of instead of instead of pay to
win its subscribe to win I'm sorry I'll
get a dick dude
oh no I just I just saying like that
this is the whole name of the game from
Microsoft is on ramping to subscription
services I won't be surprised if Sony
came up with something similar to game
pass soon yeah are doing it on PC with
origin axis Y axis has been a massive
success on xbox Ubisoft they're gonna
get in on this eventually too there's
already like 50 different Android
subscription services for games on
Android we actually own one ourselves at
mobile nation
I haven't used it myself righteous and I
just know that we this is what
everyone's doing this was a subscription
services for games and and this is the
only way they can get PC is to make them
subscribe but this is slightly off topic
as well and just to finish off this
segment let's go for it I'm not talking
way too much but for people who are
upset about Microsoft's first party and
their their ability to deliver games and
stuff like that you have to imagine that
in a world where game paths is
Microsoft's new bed and bread and butter
you subscribe to game path and Xbox Live
they need content to drive people to
subscribe like Netflix has
programming absolutely yeah in a perfect
world Microsoft would have something for
every single month of the year tequila
that's where Microsoft I believe wants
to get to he's gonna take time to get
there I think they will get there
absolutely Master Chief is gonna be the
star piece I think so I want to get
lured acting on this because I know the
halo things a little cars were he was
getting some flack back in the day so
I'm curious like how long-term I mean
this is a good thing I'll do I will say
this though you know coming to peace in
everything I have to say this one's
gonna look controverts gonna upset some
they've gotta fix the Microsoft Store
though like that that's my own like
really want to make this thing viable
man because I think right now it's and
again I don't want to expect anybody the
teams that's working on it I don't know
what but it's just not in a good state
what do you feel about that logic before
we move on as far as you know if it if
it comes and when it comes you know I've
written multiple articles about a
terrible the window stories and and I
want to believe that it was due to
structural structural problems at
Microsoft previously littlez boss was
Terry Myerson leader of the windows and
devices group that device is that that
group and Microsoft has now been split
okay now Panos Panay who creates surface
he runs his own devices division now
there's a cloud division and there is a
gaming division all of the leadership
table so there's no there's no
terramycin
telling them what to do now and I heard
at the Windows Store gaming was run by
the windows team not the Xbox team and
that was actually a point of contention
that's what I heard
so now with terramycin oh the picture
and with Windows as an entity divided up
into SEC into segments Microsoft because
it usually windows used to be at the top
that's right nah it's maxed absolutely
its services that are at the top gaming
cloud and you know surface sort of off
to the side it's the whole point of
surface like Xbox is to try and get
people to subscribe to onedrive office
so hopefully now that Phil is actually
the true leader loves when you say stuff
like that biggie well I know the Xbox
isn't happy with the way the story is
and I want to believe that they'll fix
it but again like everything it's gonna
take time I believe in you just maybe a
fast with lorca Xbox I'm really glad
that you're saying you like me when you
hold that big that the words that he
used it wasn't and it's very hard to get
that across the people but these are the
words that people use when it comes to
Phil I believe you know it's not
what he's done he's proven his track
record is proven he's he's elevated
certain aspects of he's changed the
mentality when it came to the narration
of the story that was being written as
he gains more control he's not becoming
a tyrant with the with the power
actually he's reached across the the
party lines he's congratulated them when
they make wins
it's about gaming with him and that
comes across as a genuine oh this guy is
real genuine really about the thing
about the thing about Phil Microsoft is
like they're not in a console war
they're not in the console business they
are a company a likes to build platforms
and it's part of Microsoft's mission
statement and Satya Nadella said it in
an interview recently you don't join
Microsoft to do awesome things you join
Microsoft to help other people do or
something plus the way Xbox approaches
the way Phil approaches Xbox at least
this is what the impression I get as
part of the wider Microsoft ethos is
that they want to create a platform that
all developers love to make games for so
when Phil's reaching across party lines
and stuff like that and trying to try
and a you know win good favor and and
stuff like that he's trying to build a
platform I can be biggest platform and
also provide the biggest legacy a
platform that's one of the reasons
they're going the diving deep into
backwards compatibility because they're
concise the devs you know bring your old
games with this one too you know we are
the platform and and the next and
triple-i devs
they want they're not thinking about
they're not just well of course they're
thinking about gamers today right there
they're not just thinking about today's
meetings gamers they're thinking about
the millions and millions of future
games too and that's the dilemma Xbox is
really looking at is likely because when
Amazon gets involved in this whole
console
this well when Amazon gets involved in
gaming and cloud gaming really takes off
this whole console thing is gonna seem
like ridiculously pay because huge
disruption is coming to this industry
really like this you know when when the
when internet speeds got fast enough
Netflix came along and disrupted the
whole industry with a with a service for
streaming movies internet speeds aren't
good enough for streaming games right
now but they will be one day and that's
why Microsoft is putting data centers
every damn country in the world
whereas Sony is spending their money
making games for today's gamers which is
awesome but the thing is Microsoft is
looking to the future
more and more and a lot of people don't
maybe don't like that because they want
here and now because impatient a lot of
it is let's be honest you know because
of you know I want to defend those guys
for a little bit you know because of
Microsoft's lack of first party this
generation and the fact that you know
let's be honest Sony has these
tremendous experience in big games like
God war you know it's only right that
Xbox fans will look at their platforms
say hey why can't we get you know these
titles but to your point launchers which
I do agree with you is that what what
you're painting this picture is that
they're setting up for the long game
right they're setting up data centers
and things of that nature so continue on
what you say I think I think like you
can argue that if Microsoft if Xbox has
had less well if Microsoft in general
had like less disruptive organizational
stuff like they're very structured
across the whole company terramycin gone
out and stuff like that and you could
argue that the mismanagement of
Microsoft as an organization contributed
to this lack of first party games right
now you know in a perfect world we'd
have Microsoft preparing for the future
great we'd also have those first party
games exactly what we'd have in a
perfect world but for whatever reason
hasn't happened
I've heard some horror stories about Don
Mattrick I heard okay we can stories
about we I loved it I would love to hear
one can I get wood I was told by someone
Don Mattrick didn't believe in indie
games for example yeah he didn't want he
didn't want to bother with having an
indie platformer and stuff like that
because he felt like it was you know it
would be value store or whatever I
remember just stuff like that you know
the guy he didn't get it he didn't get
gamers it was pure businessman
whereas film a little bit of both that
the horror of 20 was in 2013 in
conjunction with Terry Myerson who let's
be honest at that time you know Xbox
didn't have a seat really at the table I
did believe in it you know and this kind
of transitions actually to my next topic
which is you know the financials and
what's going on now because obviously we
do know you know that the revenue kind
of came out and you know Microsoft was
it wasn't his doom and gloom as
everybody thought yeah the Xbox division
was it brought in about you know shout
the Lord Randy had a great video on this
by the way um you yeah like they brought
in 2.25 billion in the quarter you know
it's up 18% you're gonna mean so long
and surprisingly first we gotta give
credit to Sasha right for putting fill
in that position you know and as far as
seeing like the game services and things
like that you know kind of really thrive
when technically in gamers eyes 2017 may
not have been the greatest game you know
first party game here for Xbox one but
for a profit for the division
it showed that wow they're really making
money so I guess the question I want to
bring to the roundtable and back back to
the lords and jazz is that um you know
now that you hear in these numbers you
know we're hearing this you know it acts
Xbox is being profitable it's not good
with groom think that the fanboys have
kind of put out there
well what do you see I know below King
you've been fighting that fight for a
long time looking at the chart and I'm
looking at the donation oh I like this
big
thank you so much absolutely much
appreciated law school man
so yeah so now that we've got this
information you know Lord J's like does
this go against um the whole notion the
rhetoric the narrative that it's kind of
doom and gloom for Microsoft and also
how does this translate for investment
for the future for those titles that the
Xbox one fanbase wants those first party
titles you know it's always hard to
predict the future but you know
[Music]
basically Microsoft is in a really
really good position to build for the
future and they are looking at the
disruption I mentioned by Google hired
Phil Harrison got 10 cent buying up
everyone in China and and then you are
Amazon who have you know sizeable cloud
the only cloud platform that competes
with works off Amazon could easily just
you know say oh by the way now on twitch
Prime you also get all these games who
would be disruptive like how you know
and especially if they stream to your
phones imagine that it would be massive
disruption and Sony isn't prepared for
you know and if I was like if I was a
PlayStation game I would be concerned I
am but at the same time games are really
important and they are even more
important in a world where you have a
subscription service because you need
that content you need those Netflix
originals think about that guy misses
trailers was like a new game pass was
such a great value even before they said
that the first party games would be a
come on launch exclusively through game
paths and stuff like that I know it was
a great value
you when they told you is a hundred
games for $10 I'm late if I'm a parent
right and I'm a parent and I buy a
system for my kid and I say well he can
get two games a year or I can buy this
game pass thing that will supplement you
know 120 dollars you know I want to say
something real quick before D says
anything I was even say anything D no I
was not asleep okay take care will be
less no you so that 2.5 billion it
didn't surprise me no I mean really a
billion with the B so the fact that
that's happening contradicts a lot of
like he said you know fanboy stuff like
they're not in a fanboy console war and
Lord sovereign has been predicting this
Sasha Thomas has been controlling this
whole thing from the background like
with his little I don't know if he has a
little Ouija board or he has a little
spiritual globe or something but this
man like has consistently been
predicting week by week
Wow services yeah he he's been on it and
Microsoft has been pushing in that area
and
is gonna bear fruit because it's bearing
fruit now financially they're in a
position that when it does launch when
games do launch and the services do take
off two more when it starts to release
parity that everybody who has an Xbox
has a game pass that's when you're gonna
see an explosion that's when it actually
happens because you probably would have
probably 10 to 15% of the people
whatever Xbox have game passed now so
when it gets a little bit more you're
gonna see the explosion then and then
you're gonna see all those first party
games because the revenue is there to
fund it there's all sorts of things I
could do the game pass you know I mean
especially like you know soon we're
gonna have 5g mobile data and when when
when you've got 5g all over the globe I
mean four G's still not rolled then you
scroll you know but it's good this stuff
is gonna take years but Microsoft is in
a position to capitalize this I know in
a way that some of the companies on you
know and that's why I like you get Wall
Street analysts they talk about which
company is gonna be the first to a
trillion dollar value and they're saying
Microsoft now no one would have ever
said most of five years ago right but
they have they've done so well in cloud
and competing with Amazon in that space
and corporate services and stuff like
that it could it could very well be
Microsoft not Amazon or Apple to to a
trillion dollars first not even Apple
has it I don't have to win first place
in every area for a competition you just
gotta you gotta compete well enough in
every direction for that yeah exactly
so like Microsoft is in re Xbox is in a
good position to play the long game
but that was that might suck if you're a
fan now and you want to get solving next
we gotta get to softer Damas index as he
predicted all this but um I want out
what it was kind of interesting when the
financers came out is how much third
party played a factor in today because a
lot of people give criticism the market
often reference to you know you guys
don't you know don't have a lot of you
know good original first party content
when you look at games like fortnight
and all these things like that's kind of
like the strength they cause so much you
know surge and spending on both the
consoles and to see you know those type
of things kind of contribute to the
financial numbers and stuff like that I
thought that was pretty interesting you
know and being that Xbox one X let's be
honest it's kind of the best place to
play you know third party you know plug
titles so I think that kind of helps and
goes handed on so I want to get I want
to get to Sasha Thomas in on his cuz
he's he's predicted the future he'd been
telling us all this we weren't listening
what do you feel about all this
information coming out with the Xbox
financials and so on tell us a look at
the complete arrogance its engagement
Microsoft care only cares about you
engaging with their ecosystem they don't
give a damn how you do it they just want
you there some way shape or form and
continuing to create platforms and ways
for you to engage with them on on on in
terms of the platform different
platforms in terms of price point which
is big for a lot of people like when you
create multiple way in price points for
the same product and you tell people can
you decide how you want to do this
that's attractive to people that's
attractive to people when they have a
choice as to how they can consume a
product right um a lot of these numbers
obviously even when you talk about the
the service engagement
a lot of as due to people being excited
over sea of thieves you gotta see people
who didn't have game paths before got
game passed for at the very least a
month if not for more right so you could
only see this stuff improving now with
state of decay coming out long towards
it towards the middle and also it's
gonna be it's gonna be ridiculous and
this again this is what they want to see
so yeah the the fact that the third the
the the game passed off and and the
services stuff is only going to continue
to improve just because you got more
eyes on
these products now people the
willingness for people to spend $10 and
see what it's all about is there so and
once you spend the 10 if you have one
game one game on that service that you
say you know what I'm willing to keep
paying that tend to stay here and then
it just exposes you to everything else
is there you're gonna find something
else you want to play it's a matter of
just keep continuing to create ways for
people to see different things on your
platform and continue wanting to be
engaged with it and they just they're
there they've created they're at a point
now like that says where they're in a
position to continue to expand upon that
in a way that Sony isn't and Sony again
maybe they're not showing their hand but
it feels almost irresponsible the way
they're approaching it I understand that
you're speaking to those guys who love
the first the single player like
narrative based action based experiences
I love those experiences but you I like
when you're not talking about the other
stuff that's obvious it's gonna be huge
it's a little scary for the future of
PlayStation as a as a living platform
right not as a singular platform they're
just four five six and in the same goes
for Nintendo Nintendo with you know with
the portability of the system seems like
they have an idea that you know what I
want you here all the time and I'm gonna
try to figure out a way to have you here
all the time we don't know you know how
that translates moving for we're gonna
find out more about the online stuff
soon and what not gonna be a Microsoft
cloud yeah you know what that'd be the
smartest thing to do right it would be
the absolute smartest thing to do um so
I just think it it shows that they know
what they're doing they're not gonna
please everybody all off the jumping or
piss some people off but these two
growing pains to doing something like
the fundamentals of philosophies in each
company the fundamentals for
philosophies in each company allows you
to understand where they priorities lie
they priorities lies in multiple and
game
a German spat one right
map is Cassatt the law piscatella he
said that exact word when we talked
about games past launching everybody was
concerned is it Morocco South gonna lose
money you know they're giving away their
first parties and the key word he says
what you just said law king was
engagement continued to it's coming
right man it has a single-player
component that you can play by yourself
right but the whole thought of it is to
be played with your squad before so now
you have four people engaging in this
online game and one time because you
look for your squad we actually look to
fill up a team and pop G before we go
out yeah we could play by itself but we
will like you know to have our squad and
then the chat factor that we're all
engaged sometimes we have multiple teams
in chat this is all engagement this is
all people interacting with each other
on one platform to find 12 people inside
a chat remember they open up the chat
for more people to be engaged in the
chat right even if you're driving in
your car Blake let's shout out to Jay
bone bone slave he's in his car working
while on chat with us he's engaging
right only with the Xbox app yes I'm
correct so the philosophies of each
company is showing true now like Tony
does such a great job with the single
player come here let me talk to you like
they want to whisper to you let me talk
to you I mean I let you for a second and
Microsoft is more of this speaking to
the crowd sometimes they miss a couple
of people they will miss that one-on-one
with Sony will get that one-on-one
Microsoft is trying to engage everybody
at all at one time
now it's great if you have both
platforms right it works out for you
while Nintendo like Lord sovereign says
is trying to keep that system on you you
play with it wherever you're the bow
from you're playing yes
waiting in line at the bank you're
playing iord so engagement is key with
all the companies but how they look at
it is that's the the fundamental DNA of
each company absolutely not agree
because you have a hammer and you're
saying Lord says I just want to bring
this one last point for you move on to
you in reference to that now we all
agree engagement we all agree agree a
long-term plan for Maxwell seems like it
may bear fruit my question to you is
though what about the here and now fan
the fan is said yeah that's nice but ya
ain't got no single-player game that's
nice but God was out here and ain't no
God war on Xbox you know and I'm tired
of waiting because this is what we hear
Lord just like we we hear like Marcus
what are they doing and in the consensus
is if they don't have anything by e3 I
mean I'm getting rid of this thing man
like what do you say to those people who
may be losing faith who are on the cusp
I would honestly tell them to just buy
Playstation if you want what PlayStation
has buy a Playstation because it's
impossible to just magic up a God of War
and yeah maybe Microsoft screwed up and
they should have had something ready
high-quality games ready and it would
have been Scouts you know stuff like
that
hopefully you know like they screwed up
you know these games got canceled
phantom dust got canceled other legends
got canceled you know we don't need to
go through all that lots of game to the
console and they screw they made they
made the wrong bets on certain second
parties and and things weren't wrong you
could say yeah Microsoft screwed up
they're gonna work to fix it they're
hiring top-tier talent to do that and
I've had the realization stuff like that
but it's gonna take time so if you want
the here and now I want the best games
best single-player games here and now
your your main choice is to buy a
Playstation or play one of those 500
games in your backlog because I when
people say this to me like on Twitter
Xbox has no games I just blot them
just like do you have time to play all
these games such an asinine argument
because my backlog has hundreds of games
in it yes they're not first polygons
right who cares
exactly so your Blacklock disagrees it's
like to play all these games you know
and it's just like you know you say wet
where are these first point games you
click on their profile then they've got
like a Pearson listed but no I like Sony
fans often sony fanboys often seem more
concerned about Xbox than Xbox fans
interested I want to play games at the
end of the day let's say that tomorrow
light you know you have all these these
fans I'm not gonna go and get really
specific people really like you see
people like oh they they want the they
want all of this like oh I just want the
brand to be better I just want I'm like
no you don't like at the end of the day
there are some people that claims that
they want the brand to be better but
let's say that if Microsoft came out at
e3 and they dropped nothing but great
news she showed a bunch of people
initiatives that they're doing stuff the
same people saying they want the brand
to be better gonna be the same people
they're gonna be slow key disappointed
like well man what am I gonna talk about
on Twitter for the next one loke want
the brand to do bad because that's how
they're building their brand right
because a lot of people look at this as
a competitive you know space and that's
fine I mean that competition definitely
makes it better for us as the gamer you
know at the end of the days it's like
the poll we had maybe to our ILP at
polls ago and it was just like if a
brand is disappointing you that much
again it's okay to demand better no
one's saying not to we didn't want to
you know not go against that but it
comes to a point that if you keep
getting consistently disappointed and
the said company's not doing what you
needed to do then you
okay to mention that that sister like
you know if you want to go out great go
out you know make a hole to our podcast
saying that this is a disappointing I
don't like this but what I see that it's
a problem on you and not them is when
you do the next week or the next day
it's like if you if okay if you have an
expectation of wanting this brand to be
better but you don't give them the
enough time to make this band Brett like
figure eight makes a video last week
saying I don't like the fact that
there's no first party titles then
figure eight makes the same podcast
again a week later saying I don't like
that they don't make there's literally
no way you can make from point A of
making last week to point a making this
week of controlling anything like that
there's no way shout out the laws
demarcus daus he says with the damage
control podcast on both that is true no
see but here's the thing it's like I
don't understand where these people like
you can't get you don't give them
realistic values on when they can fix
this you can't make a podcast once a
week claiming that you want this brand
to fix but you can't fix stuff in a week
like if you made if you made a video
like three years ago like you know I'm
not happy with what they are and then
you make a video in enough time where I
feel like they could relatively answer
your your concerns that's different but
people literally keep making the same
video every day and I'm like who's like
I don't get I don't get how you
realistically in a realistic expectation
expected to be fixed you know what
happens is it's not that it's just that
this it's always a reaction to what
happens on the other side right they
make a video and it was clearly but I
think say I'm doing this for like they
literally be fooling themselves that
they're doing this for a brand when
they're doing it for their their own
because I mean again you make a video
right and it let's say there's nothing
out on the Sony side right then two
weeks later got a war comes out you're
gonna say it again right
we don't have this and then if Detroit
comes out and it's a it's a it's a top
tier game right they're gonna say it
again when Spiderman comes out same
things gonna happen like the same
arguments gonna be there like that it's
like you said it's for cliques because
you know there's gonna be there's gonna
be a polarizing conversation around it
it's gonna happen
you know and in the in the funny part is
is people reacting like I will say that
you know Microsoft's had plenty of stuff
and I would say the only thing that's
really when it comes down to it I think
people want to see more of Game of the
Year contenders and not just games in
general quality at level stands I will
say as of right now there's only been a
couple games that Microsoft's generated
that could even be a game of your
container as much as I don't really
particularly care for sunset overdrive
that was okay with your contender with
your contender I'm saying a game that
could potentially be game of the year
depending on what came out that year
okay relatively a game that has quality
that could potentially be game of the
Year contender but it's not it's fought
it would compete with something like GTA
5 got Awards like something that is
quality but could be game of the year in
some formal way but it couldn't because
of games that came out that year it's
gone no I understand I know all I want
we'll move on because we don't stop a
little too long you know one thing I
want is just for them for games like
sunset overdrive games like rise if they
have controlled IP which some cases they
do some cases they don't I just would
like them to like we you know we talked
before you know invest in the sequel
because some things that I like that
Sony does is that they don't kind of I
don't say give up on the first attempt
when necessarily it wasn't the most
financial because it Microsoft has
control of a lot of properties that
deserves equals in my opinion so I would
I would like to see that you know that's
just me but I actually am a little just
just to just add to your point I
actually think this is the the biggest
area of Microsoft's failing yes they
make these games and they market them
wanna break they push all this marketing
they give the game a cliffhanger ending
all this merchandise all these you know
all this narrative stuff surrounding the
game no sequel you never we're probably
honestly will probably never get a
sequel and it breaks my heart and and
the thing is that those are the
instances where Microsoft pisses me off
the most and it's like they they they
drill into us get invested in our IP get
investor IP and then they don't do
anything with it
and they've done this repeatedly yes
it's almost as if the home run is not
hit with the first attempt they just
fall back on it and it's just you know
and that's the part like we know what
Forza gears that halo do we understand
that but it's just one of those things
we just hope you know there's games that
have a so
[Applause]
yes what dream what is going on all
right so there's gonna be a two-parter
we're gonna talk about the drama first
then the game yes so back in January if
you guys remember so Quantic there were
some articles that came out in French
media outlets um basically accusing
Quantic Dream is some really toxic
workplace behavior racist you know
racist stuff sexist stuff that David
cage-like vehemently denied right um and
it sort of stayed there after afterwards
like he came out and said no this is not
true we're gonna defend ourselves um we
you know with the full might of the law
but it kind of went silent and now on
about four months later it comes to pass
that they have actually sued these
publications which is a first ever and I
get in in the video game space where
a developer has turned around and sued
or exactly for um basically what they
believe to be libelous works for Lemone
so the funny and interesting thing about
this is my perspective on it is this the
fact that they're they're suing a
publication for basically for opinions a
and but opinions based on accounts from
people who've worked there um is
something it's kind of nuts because this
sort of stuff comes down to he said she
said right right
um when there when the publication is
saying yeah we're being put to all this
litigation but we're sticking by our
guns meaning our sources are correct we
we did everything we needed to do from
you know the literary side to make sure
we're getting both sides of the story we
and three different publications went
you know publish this stuff so it's not
like nobody looked at this stuff and
said no oh we shouldn't be doing this
like there's some when it were
approaching this from the wrong angle ah
you know we we have to make sure that
everybody's well represented here so
that it doesn't come back to bite us in
the rear and the fact that nobody said
that it just feels like okay what is
David cage trying to prove now right is
this a bullying thing and another
interesting thing about it is that he
waited he made these statements when it
first happened right hmm and they went
silent and now four months later is when
they come out and say we're suing them
that gives you to me if you're half if
you're saying vehemently I did not do
this none of this is going on at my
company then you immediately sue them
right you don't wait it almost feels
like he said okay let me let me let me
get everybody into it into the boardroom
right and we're gonna talk about these
things and figure out how to fix this
stuff and then come at them when
we've wiped everything squeaky-clean um
and everybody's on board that they're
not they know they're not gonna this
stuff is behind us they're not gonna
talk exactly are you supposed to hide
when you're doing something as
unprecedented as trying to take you're
trying to a media publication into court
for reliable as I eat you're lying
which is not the case right um then
that's a problem that's a problem
because if anything let's say my theory
is correct that he spoke to some people
and made sure the people every everybody
was on board with the company message
right let's say somebody really wasn't
on board with that and something comes
out the ramifications for his company it
could be potentially devastating right
and then the fact that they do this
right before the game just went gold
right and they posted this huge picture
with everybody happy like yeah the game
sold for one big happy family
obviously you want you don't want the
game to be in a negative light as it's
getting ready to come out right you
don't want the company to be a negative
light so I just want to know what you
guys feel about this particular
situation then we'll talk about whatever
Lord says what do you know about what's
going on with this whole Quantic Quantic
Dream thing and what's your opinion nope
I don't follow PlayStation news that's I
played heavy rain I didn't like it
that's all I've got Todd that's all you
got that that I just want to ask you one
question that familiar with everything
and I know you have to be careful here
and I want to get you in trouble all I
was saying all I want to ask is just
from the standpoint of a developer suing
a media outlet or media outlets
what just what you're feeling on that in
general well I know that France has
different media lost some other
countries I don't really know the
details about what it is and stuff like
that I mean just the act of suing them
it's probably enough but they're
basically they're making a statement to
say these things aren't true and we're
willing to fight it I about in court I
don't know
I mean if it's if it's slant if it's
slander and if it really wasn't true
then the call decide it could be a
really bad move because you never know
the thing things might come out in court
that Quantic Dream would would be a
Quantic nightmare one thing that was
mentioned that could potentially be
troublesome further like for the pub the
outlet is that they're they're probably
gonna have to prove that that the way
they acquired their sources right and
it's the way that they approach they
didn't approach it from a position of
bias that they were willing meaning that
they reached out the Quantic Dream for
for comment before any of this stuff
came out so they're gonna have to prove
all of that so within that their sources
are probably gonna have to come out and
they're therein lies the whole issue
with you know journalistic integrity and
and how you handle things like that
right and how much of that has to come
out it's funny because just the other
day I was watching news um David
Copperfield had to give up one of his
tricks in court yeah because a guy a guy
got injured
he didn't voluntarily like you know say
that he wanted to be part of the trick
they chose him out of the crowd and he
fell or something like that that he sued
him for like yeah hurt my foot and they
was like are you okay okay he was like
yeah brain damaged like I don't mention
baby
yeah after after he went home and talked
to somebody like what are you crazy
didn't sue like this today's uh thing is
suing um that's neither here nor there
let me let me tell you what this whole
thing is okay first of all it's a civil
case okay it's not a criminal case so
the civil case you can bring up a
frivolous lawsuit and you can put that
to to court and the motions right right
and then yeah it doesn't it will bounce
no place it will go absolutely no place
they don't even really defend the thing
it will get dismissed because it's
frivolous but then doing this you're
showing good face your face is good it's
like a couple that you hear they're
gonna get divorced right but they got to
go to Tony's wedding because it's a
family event and when they go to Tony's
wedding the whole family is smiling and
they taking pitches right knowing damn
well they're gonna get divorced so it's
so much problems that's in Quantic
Dream's but this game has to come out
this game has to sell and we don't need
to divide people into saying oh are we
going to purchase on the grounds of
morality are we going to just purchase a
game because it's such a great game
shout out to the most interactive movie
game ever um that was for you death uh
yeah definitely watching you baby but
it's like of course we know that they're
gonna do PR and they have to clean it up
a bit and after the game comes out and
after the game does its numbers and it
starts to die down then you're gonna see
the lawsuit be withdrawn and it's
whatever because like Lord sovereign
said it's hearsay hearsay is admissible
in civil court but once they start
digging I don't expect it to go any
further and any more facts other than
the facts that were released before you
know people complaining because whatever
you perceive to be a slight may not be a
slight on my part like me and addict
little thing there
Atika later on sue me and safe emotional
distress talking my my screen like I'm
on
oh yeah pretty much I mean the timing is
interesting obviously you know I do want
to shout out I do like to show a lot of
it I like the devil I've got I'm in a
tough spot cuz I don't like what's going
on behind the scenes but I like the game
and I want the game we're gonna pick up
the game it's just one of those things
that it just pains me to know that if
this stuff is true you know and they're
going through these kind of like what I
call like public court of opinion things
like to try to sway influence if that's
the case like I was saying I'm a little
concerned about that so it's gonna be
interesting to see how this plays out
I'm the only girl I kinda want to make
is that they they were three media
outlets I believe French media outlets
that came out with that but they're only
suing the jungle right so that I thought
was interesting one haven't been
quote-unquote served yet one that wasn't
served though they were some threatening
letters before they actually went
through the with the litigation on the
other too bright but they Felix they
were expecting some kind of notice that
they were being sued but nothing could
the third one just be bigger than they
are so they can't sue them like
everybody lordy right no bad it could
they legitly sue them and no they
getting get away with it well this is
the thing if you're going this far with
it you have to make sure your ducks in a
row right so if this third or this other
third publication is starting with the
hammer just had stuff like that like
it's not going to be sued they had to
have a hand and actually bringing all
this information to the forefront so
that's that so let's get into the game
real quick
demo came out last week mm-hmm if you
are a fan of Indigo Prophecy of you're a
fan of heavy rain to souls this is
straight-up a David cage game
it's just blown out to the umpteenth
level the game is beautiful it is a
gorgeous game it is a triple-a game in
terms of absolute auction value mom I
got to play through like three
permutations of the scenario that they
that they gave us in the demo right
which is the one that we saw at e3 last
year example and it's just blowing out a
little bit more I will say this um I
don't know if it's if it's a digital
purchase for me it might be a disc
purchase that I that I finished once
you're finished if they're done yeah I
see exactly to me David cage has always
been good about giving you that
choose-your-own-adventure right where
books on Gruffalo shouts to their vision
so we all grew up with and in each game
he's expanded upon then giving you more
choices right but the ideal is to get to
that point where you know the analogy of
throwing a pebble in a pond and seeing
how all the ripple effects affect
everything around it right and that's
that's where everybody wants to get
right I talked about way back when about
um who's the bioshock guy ken Levine we
want him to do something called it you
know digital Legos where every
everything you did affected everything
else that happened right that's a
difficult thing to do right so in that
respect this isn't that yet
this is just a birdcage formula blown
out more mm-hmm
so you're gonna have more permutations
and more things that happen and more
small things that happen during the
course of the story that effect bigger
things that happen so in that respect I
say yeah it's it definitely improves
upon that formula but it's still finite
it's still not you know and it's still
limited like they give you an
environment and there's certain things
you can mess with in the environment and
you look at you can't touch everything
in the environment there's specific
things that don't you to focus on
exactly and these time limits and stuff
with some things as well so that that
part of it if you're into that that sort
of game and that sort of mechanic it's
just that blown out right it takes it
takes it to the Telltale Games and it
takes it to old David cage games
now if you have issues with how he
handles like themes and stuff like that
well against the David cage game he
handles his themes would like the
subtlety of a hammer like it's not shut
up to the check which is cheaper nyquil
or Detroit I'm dead games you know
kognito likes these have games some
people might find it boring because you
know later we might be just to buy that
game tonight we got a man like that to
me it's gonna be one of those things if
you like those games already you like it
if not I don't know that it's bringing
on anybody new maybe for the looks the
looks of are hot so you might want to
jump in and try this out the controversy
actually made me a question for Laura
Carney no actually it was a we're going
over are we gonna say it okay so real
quick in the world of kendo which
couldn't wait to get to oh yeah new
president
you know pronounce his name fully
chanterelle through Cour Oh
pretty much you know twenty years
younger he grew up in the Famicom era
you know so I thought that was
interesting you know expert in marketing
clothes which is impressive I awana with
42 when he took over what our years too
old to play over fluent English close
ties to Pokemon like I said which I
thought was key because obviously that
you think that's comment so I thought
that's interesting new blood in the
Nintendo line but what I want to get to
which is the newest hottest thing in the
streets right now the Nintendo switch
has been blown
wide-open fakemon fixable hack it's been
hacked this is actually not on the
software level so it's on the hardware
level and the Tegrity pretty much makes
it fake news no no this is official this
is not fake news this is a fish I can
give you links give official news yes
let's be repaired one at every hundred
people were able to do this
no anybody first of all this cannot be
fixed to a firmware update this is on
the hardware side when you take off the
joy cons of the Nintendo switch you know
how you have those rails where the joy
can't slide on it's basically some type
of USB thing that goes through and
overpasses the BIOS and it starts its
own boot rom they cannot fix this
through software they will have to come
out with new Nintendo hardware to get
around it now obviously you know we
assume Nintendo is going to update the
next level of Nintendo switches with an
what's called a new a Tegra trip which
doesn't have that exploit but as of
right now they cannot do anything to fix
this I just want to bring this to the
roundtable let's get it to jazz it's
getting to everybody real quick your
thoughts on Nintendo president and the
switch being hacked ok well switch being
hacked obviously is a huge headache for
Nintendo they're gonna have to release a
new one apparently can be hacked with a
single wire like a little blue critter
you know this horse is what buried the
Dreamcast you know I mean I remember at
school kids were trading booth discs the
Dreamcast shot like 30 games on them you
didn't even need a cape or you just slip
disc in boom you hacked console so huge
a headache obviously for Nintendo and
they need to fix it as soon as possible
but that basically all the Nintendo
switches that are out in the world now
are totally susceptible and obviously as
we all know as we discussed
the margins on consoles arrays the fin
you need those games to make money and
this is a huge problem for Nintendo so
yes it's a shame you know but uh but
I've always said the Nintendo hardware
has always been shoddy I feel like you
know and Nintendo people like the the
most passion in the world because I mean
the intend I make some amazing games but
they're hard way is always crappy like
my gang cube just died randomly we was a
joke I'm sorry
lordy lurking I'm pretty sure Lord Lord
cognitive favorite phrase is going to be
used for Lord jazz anymore all for all
the janky hardware they produce they
have amazing ideas this week the switch
is like the form factor of the switch is
like this amazing idea tub such a
powerful console is such a small
portable devices and it works really
well and no of the manufacturers have
been trying this for years like Nokia
with the n-gage I'm sorry the Nvidia
shield is like it didn't have the
software and Nintendo did have a
software and they they saw the because
people always criticize Nintendo for
like and not doing more stuff on mobile
because because of how Pokemon go blow
up and stuff like then this is
Nintendo's response because they've been
massively successful within yes and
there
switch is sort of like the evolution of
what they learned is amazing
I just wish Microsoft well that's the
whole platform open to it was like I
didn't say which is there's a
possibility some things may be in place
he just saying that that's because they
let xbox live on those so that
conceptually could happen conceptually
that's why I'm saying is the Nintendo
switch is a great console and it feels
this sort of this gap where you can take
a powerful console with you which Sony
failed to do with Vita and Microsoft
have never even bother trying to do
right so it is a shame you know and
hopefully they can get this fixed I mean
it looks it looks like they rushed the
switch out of the door I've seen that
I've seen the teardown of the switch
internals
just looks poorly made flat plastic you
surface hardware when I have like I got
service book to write here it is there
it is a symphony of engineering
excellence which like this plastic e toy
[Laughter]
the fact that you can you can crack it
with a single wire just say to me that
they rush this thing no and that's now
you don't blame Tegra though because the
the fault is actually in the Tegra chip
it that's where the exploit lies though
it's like they have a flaw Thunder
fundamentally in on the chipset so I
thought that was kind of interesting I
mean that affects the relationship
wouldn't intend to Integra going for
because they had such they've been so
profitable for these guys it might be a
you know on Hardware part like taggers
fall at the end of the day this is like
the whole like you know Microsoft and
and platinum thing like they did give
that job to them so like that was
judgment maybe maybe that was bad
judgment on there and at the end of the
day like you can't even really blame
them on a hardware side because you know
it is their fault and that's probably
gonna put some kind of fault between
them but it's hard to litter it's hard
on unlike a hardware thing to be perfect
bad for Nintendo because there's no that
could have used
I couldn't they couldn't have used any
of the chipset to make that consoles at
the nobody does this listen you know
when it's real when it's real is when a
certain low it shows me how to do it
[Laughter]
right now my Nintendo backlog is very
minor
I have at least probably five games top
six Nintendo has a little bit of time
because the hack is just that it's not
an easy thing to do right now yet once
this thing that you show like that's not
even in production yet so once it is
and once they continue to refine these
hacks and make it so that it's almost
it's easy for anybody to do that's when
you really have to work at this point
though I mean you talk about like 18
million which is Kinect so they are
thinking about revisions and how they
got to move the timeline timeline up for
for the revision that they had planned
for me
what's the hack that happened really
fast did the switch throw a better
version of a powerful version is all an
intricate plot by Lorde kognito
to get the switch pro with the Tegra 2
check out the possible I gotta restate
it okay the IRA they went to Nintendo
with that exploit to let them know hey
we got you know that this is on this is
on record so we're we're okay there's a
Nintendo they just said they're not
going to comment at this point but it's
common knowledge that they won't be
pumping out a reel in very soon Integra
and like Lord sovereign said this may be
long turned speeds up you know that
possible version to you know what a
better technotrekker wait that the
robbers yes came up to Nintendo knocked
on the door with their gun and said
listen you got the goods if you don't
play ball with us
we're gonna actually put this out to the
crash they notified Nvidia and Nintendo
and others who plan to you notify them
right and the problem was it they were
like this is what it is work on it right
and then once they saw other hacking
groups came up with the same exploit
they said oh we got to put it out there
because then you can thing with
everybody now first but here's the funny
part y'all the people who actually are
using the exploit right now Lord oh they
aren't using it to power games because
they intend oh so terrible that they
don't have an internal save situation
they're using the hack to put to save
their data on SD card which something
the Tendo should already be offering for
that program which I find is hilarious
so they don't lose anything cuz right
now if your switch breaks you lose your
data this
one of the major complaints against the
switch you're mean so I thought that was
hilarious but yes it nor King is like
you said it's literally a stick them up
I didn't know it was so much intrigue in
coffee shenanigans going on this has got
to be the best I know that part of this
segment is gonna be race so I just want
y'all to understand I'm having such a
good time knowing that the bank robbers
ran up to the train okay we got the
goods upon you putting the money in the
bag are you gonna discount before we end
the show
Lord Atticus I know when it comes to it
I enjoyed that they have a little bit of
a more probably person that was born
around my generation being put into the
president and I'm not gonna say once
again on one side iron Lord podcaster
not support piracy but I am gonna say
[Music]
real quick okay when the news of a
console exclusive from your preferred
platform is also announced to go to PC
does this negatively affect your view of
that console the answers will be a yes
exclusive on PC devalue the console I
own be no game for PC doesn't affect me
as a console gamer or see I don't care
PC master-race rules you all please Rock
the Vote hit the ILP Twitter poll when
it hard when it goes up Lord jazz thank
you for dealing with all the shenanigans
in the road for going over a little bit
longer than normal but it was an
absolute pleasure to have you man thank
you for coming through
where can the farm people find you what
other articles or projects that you have
cooking up well I mentioned at the start
we're currently working on see if the if
they've state of decay to preview or
edge got tons of 4k footage go off next
week also we've already written a
preview I believe or to go live next
week I think state of decay to Shh I'm
not supposed to be able to talk about it
but it's shaping up quite nicely you
guys played it it's so pretty I wasn't
that excited about it I'm a big fan of
the original but I saw it at e3 last
year and I wasn't impressed with it at
e3 but what I've seen now as made me a
lot more interested in it seems a lot
deeper than the first game so yeah cool
wait for that other than that I am
probably just gonna be playing a load of
question for you since you've played
state of decay you say oh well no I've
applied the sequel all right let's say
you let's say in perfect world you've
played the sequel is there access to
hacks which is rocket play to Nintendo
game in an Xbox game awesome thank you
so much for coming through these out
choices guys Lourdes addict where can I
find people find you well you can find
me leaving the podcast that's for sure
going to sleep to be on acquire one of
those snug you'd be good in this podcast
because you'd be putting me to sleep all
over I like to promote the Lord addict
with what you got
I reassure everyone coming by appreciate
you guys coming by I'm out no doubt lore
sovereign pleasure to have always what
do you got
not for weight a lot of people find you
enjoying games now be bothered by
sometimes I will be playing God of War
well yeah but big shout out to Lord just
for coming through man really appreciate
it
but Lord King oh my god you're hilarious
today I can't even look at you
first of all I would like to say thank
you for putting a voice to these crazy
tweets I'm oh man Lord just like really
now anytime you tweet I'm here your
voice and it's fantastic oh thank you
coming through trust me it's it puts a
lot of things into context now I'm like
okay I can hear the voice now and then
the whole history with the trolling man
you are the best
I don't you pay attention to my tweets
put your first mentions now listen I got
a thing cooking up guys and I got this
question and I really want to know do
you want me to get a tattoo of the iron
Lords at e3 on my chest right here on
this side you know the logo ah or Oh or
do you want on me to do the one chip
challenge now if you don't know about
this pacquiao chip is like the hottest
jalapeno ghost chip never I want you to
get a tattoo of your World of Warcraft
girlfriend - or both but the details
coming out we work on on the patreon the
patreon is gonna go up and then y'all
can actually vote with your dollars
saying we're gonna put King in that
chair and it's gonna be live you watch
me go can we vote find your world to
work oh yeah I could do that too
right now she's running through the
streets of Warcraft doing other things
with other guys Chanel yes I know that
guy no listen Alps are the sexiest ones
that's why he knows that everything
social but I really I'm really serious
about this I want you guys either tune
in and check me die by fire of mouth oh
you catch me dying by the needle ah so I
don't know which way you want me to die
[Laughter]
has been spread once again thank you
Lord just for coming through huge huge
fan of you that you are absolutely
awesome miss to deal with all the
foolishness here in Rio I give you a lot
of credit but it's sad out - you would
love what you're doing also I want to
shout out to all the people to chat
absolutely lit tonight oh I'm in today
fantastic everybody's fun engaging we've
got a lot of things cooking up like what
King says for his patron other good
stuff also want a shout out motel in the
network today I'm gonna chat you
actually please check out his latest
interview he had turned 10 her turn 10
studios that's it for all tick so please
catch that was really informative
obviously the multiverse is gonna go up
tomorrow they're gonna talk all about
infinity want to make sure you guys go
hit that infinity what definitely will
shake the world and shot the anchorman
shout the fame and it's a shot to fame
come to any channel a lot of the
multiverse they always always a source
love support us make sure hitting that
like and all that good stuff
gonna dusty front 5 point 13 was up with
each pontus talking about all the ladies
stuff going on with the war mind if
anybody who cares that's that but
everyone please enjoy your Sunday have a
good time we're out of here peace